欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课。
同学们,第五节我们来讲一个关于爆款标题组合方法中的第一种方法。
流量稳定的中性爆款标题怎么样组合,才能够让我们的爆品持久的稳定。
我们在运营的过程中,很多朋友都遇到过,为什么我的产品这个爆款前面几个月或者是几周流量都非常好?
为什么接着下面就是我的爆品流量就没有了呢?
无论我怎么推广,它的流量越来越少。
那么你有没有去检查你所用的这个词在标题中用的是什么样的词?
为什么会导致你的流量不稳定?
因为你的流量是跟词是有直接的关系的。
你的词用的不好,或者是说你的词本身自带的流量范围就比较小。
那么无论你是怎么样推广,你的流量都是有限的。
比如说你就在一个小池塘里面这些流量,如果你用一些大的流量的词,那么你就相当于在一个更大的池塘里面去找客户。
是不是能够找到更多的客户?是不是这个逻辑?
用词非常的关键。
用词也会决定你的爆品的持久性。
那么这节课我们就是来解决你这个爆品不稳定的问题的。
这节课的方法就是组中性标题。
它的公式是这样的,我们先来记住一个公式。
第一个,前面都是通用属性词,前面都是通用属性词。
这里的数量可以写N个,意思就是数量不限,你有多少都可以写。
但是整个标题尽可能的带100个字符,开始写的时候标题字符在100个以内,那么一定要包含一个产品的核心词,加上应用场景。
应用场景如果是你的产品没有特定的应用场景,那么可以不写,那么你就可以直接写前面这一段就可以了。
没有必要写应用场景,应用场景只针对某些行业的某些产品,并不是所有的行业都要写应用场景的。
所以说不要自己把自己误导了,一定要灵活的应用,一定要结合自己的产品的特性,关键词的类型,再结合这个公式去写,那么你才能做出更加符合你们这个行业的标题。
那么我们下面来举个例子,产品核心词,产品的核心大词,我们来讲一下这个大词的一个定义。
其实这个核心产品大词,其实就是我们所说的产品词,也就是三级类幕的产品词。三级类幕,至少至少是三级类幕。比如说T恤它是一种产品,手机是一种产品,袜子,手提包都是一种产品。
如果你只,比如说这个手提包,你只用包这个关键词,这就不是产品词了。
这个包属于一个类幕了,包属于一个类幕,类幕词了。手机的话,它前面还有很多类型的手机,所以说它是一个产品词,比如说袜子,袜子,袜子里面前面还有很多种袜子,前面很多种袜子,那么你这个袜子就是你的产品词。
你前面加的这些属性,以及什么品牌的手机,什么样的手机,都是一些精准词,一小类的精准词。
所以一定要把我们的核心产品大词弄清楚,只有核心产品大词你弄清楚了,把它定在这个位置了,那么你前面写的这些属性词就越来越精准了,而且是非常的有用了。
那么我们现在来举一个例子,来让大家感受一下,以及能够让大家更加直观的去理解这个公式和这个标题的做法。
首先我们来看一下这个案例,产品词是贵一这个词,它的特征的话,中性标题它写出来的特征就是,可以随时换产品的款式,也就是这个产品的链接,我的标题做出来之后,我的这个款式,产品的款式,图特指哪一个款式,我可以换,把A款换成B款,把C款换成B款。
你们其他的行业也是一样的逻辑,当你某个产品,比如说A产品有多个款式,那么你发的时候可能是发A1款,A2款,A3款没发,那么你在发A1款的时候用了这个链接,这个是中性标题的链接,那么你觉得这个款好像不太行,转化不太好,点击也不好,那么你就直接在原来这个链接上把A2款换上去,或者是把A3款换上去,
这就是中性标题,非常明显的一个特征。如果是这个主图或者是这个图片效果不好,那么我可以随时更换我的款式。这样的话,那么你的这个链接是不是就能够持续的沉淀数据充分的发挥作用呢?就不至于这个链接沉淀了三个月,或者是两个月,发现效果不好,数据已经很多了,但是你就直接把这个链接舍弃了。
那就是非常可惜的一种做法,所以你一定要让这些链接的数据得到的充分发挥作用。首先我们来看一下它的关键词特征。特征呢,我们就选去选近12个月,流量相对稳定的,稳定的。大词也要有,精准词也要有,长尾词也要有,也要有。我们前面所讲的那个购款标题的标准里面,也是有这三个类型的关键词的。
这三个类型的关键词,就能够确保你整个间接的流量的覆盖度,流量的稳定性,以及流量的一个自然排名的提升的容易程度。所以说一定要加上这几个,这几个类型的关键词。首先我们来看下面的这些关键词。这个关键词的搜索指数是这样的,这个关键词指数是最高的,要往这边,再到这里。
再到这里,再到这里,再到这里,再到这里。它是逐渐下降的,理解吧?搜索指数是从上到下下降的。就像我刚,我们之前在那个关键词指数里面去查一个词根,整个列表里面,它的搜索指数都是向下的。所以说向下,往下降低的。那么我这里的收集的关键词也是这样的,是向下,向下的。首先我要确定一个产品词,产品词的话,
这个就是产品词,产品词里面我要缩缴到某一类产品,比如说发泡印的产品,那么我就把这个定义为我的产品的大词,比如说这个我就定义为产品的大词,产品大词是吧?这个产品大词已经定义了,那么我是不是要开始找通用属性词,N个通用属性词,第一个通用属性词是什么?这个是通用属性词的,这是一个,你看,直接
我也写在这里,一,这个是一个通用的属性词,那么我就写在这里是写第二个,第二个,那么第三个通用的属性词是这个,通用的属性词,第三个,这个第三个,通用属性词第四个就是这两个,我在前面这里我也写了,第四个就是这个,前面还有,你看这里,这里,是不是我从来都没有出现过重复的词,这里你看
你看这里,这里,这里是第六,这是第七,这是第八,你看,我全部都是对应的这里,你看到没有,对应这里,对应这里,这些都一一对应,我,你看我这里面的词,有重复的吗,没有重复的,那么我的核心的词就是这个词产品词,如果是我归类到这里的话,那么它属于某一个类别的产品,这个的话就是一个大的产品范围,这个的话就是一个大的产品范围,这个的话就是一个大的产品范围,这个的话就是一个大的产品范围,这个的话
就是一个小类的产品范围,我通过这些属性逐渐的压缩,或者是说我通过这些属性,我已经覆盖非常非常多的类型的词,跟这个产品相关的词,跟这个产品相关的各种属性,我都写在里面了,也就是说,我这个链接,我的产品的款式或者是类型,我可以发非常多的种类的,所以说它的图可以用很多种类型的图,如果这个不好,我可以换
换成另一个,如果另一个不好,那我可以再换另一个,这样的覆盖看,是不是它能够随时可以换产品款式,因为我这个标题是属于定制的标题,且是中性的标题,我没有指定,中性的意思就是我没有指定具体的某一个类,某一个款,某一个颜色,某一个属性,我只代表我这个产品里面所有的品类都可以
为什么我可以这样写呢?因为客户下不了单,不能直接下单,我这个是定制链接,所以说当他看到收的这些词,无论他收哪个,只要我做好了排名,那么我的这个产品的链接都能够呈现出来之后,你的这个链接里面所放的一个产品图一定是当前这个市场上比较受欢迎的那种类型的款式,那么他被点击的概率就非常大,只有好了,
主图的款式,当前市场比较热门的偏好的款式放在这里面,只要他收了某一个词,只要他看到了这个款式,我都能做这种类型的,所以说他进来的话,他就能够根据他的需求去定制,另一个就是他可以通过任意一个关键词搜索进来之后,我在详情语里面一定是布局很多与这些属性相关的一些介绍,或者是说一些我们能够做
做的款式,那么这就是我们所说的一个中性标题的一个好处,以及如何制作的一个标准的一个过程。我们再来看一个下面的这个例子,比如说我看,你看我刚才里面这边的关键词是不是没有这个定制logo的,我是自己加一个营销池的,这是我自己加的,相当于营销池,这个标题我可以从这里面挑选。
这个部分的词来进行组合第二个标题,比如说我确定了这个产品词一样的,以及跟这个这个词作为结尾词,也就是第二个词作为结尾词的时候,我们前面讲过一个词跟加结尾词,这个是第一个搜索指数大的作为结尾词,这个是第二个搜索指数大的作为结尾词,那么这个作为结尾词的时候,前面就可以根据我们从这里面,比如说我挑选了,你按照顺序不一定都是
合适你的,你一定要去挑选,按照这个顺序去挑,比如说这个挑一个,这个是一,这是一,那么这个是第二,那么我挑选第二个,我挑选第二个,这个第三,我挑选第三,你看我选的时候是不是,不一定按照那个顺序,但是我可以跳过这个,我比如说我这个不用,或者是不适合我用,我就不用,这个也不适合我用,我就不用,我就直接跳到这里,看到吗?就是这样,所以
我讲的这个的话,通用于所有的行业,并不是说只有我们这个行业适合用,当你理解了这个规则跟这个逻辑了之后,你就按照这种思路去做,因为你的方法,如果是你不会灵活的变成你的行业的,那么你这个生效的概率就很低,也就是我前面,我前面所讲的这些方法,主标题的这些方法,
你要学的是什么,学的是思路和框架,你学它的框架跟思路,你有了这个框架跟思路的时候,你就按照这种思路去做自己的标题就可以了,如果是你现在听起来感觉不是特别懂,那么就是可以多听一两次,然后真正的去组标题,你只有去组了你才知道,你从组标题中去领悟去感受,你就能够真正的
知道你是不是真的掌握了这个方法,然后再通过你后期去推广去验证,那么你的领悟会更深,这个方法才能真正的内化成你自己的方法,你才能够在你的这个行业或者是你换行业换店铺的时候,你一样可以灵活的把这些方法迁移应用到其他的地方,才能够真正的发挥作用。
因为你听了某一种方法,你只会的某一种方法,因为你不懂得这个里面背后的一些思路,你学的时候不要只学方法,你要学习里面的思路,因为那个思路是可以适用于各个行业的,但是方法或者是说你选的那个词只是在某个品类生效,但是你如果是方法沿用,那就是通用于这个品类的。好了,这个就是我们
报款标题组合中的其中的一种标题的组合方法,就是中性标题的做法。这样的话,你的爆品才能够持续的稳定。那么接下来,就开始行动去做一到三个标题,或者是四到五个标题。如果有条件,做好标题,直接进行一个推广,去看看你的效果怎么样吧。好了,这节课就先讲到这里。下节课我们继续讲第二种爆品标题的
答案